as was widely expected hardliner ibrahim
raisi is well ahead in the vote count
after iran's presidential election the
three other candidates had already
congratulated the judiciary chief
the official final announcement is due
to come within hours
activists had called for an election
boycott after several contenders were
excluded
leaving only four in the race none of
them considered to be
serious rivals to raising voter turnout
was low at less than 50 percent
here are the results so far as announced
by
iran's interior ministry
given that vote counting is still
continuing these are the initial results
mr ibrahim has more than 17 million
eight hundred thousand votes
mr rezai more than three million three
hundred thousand votes
mr hemati more than two million four
hundred thousand votes
and mr
an apparent landslide victory but on a
very low
turnout
yes uh this is uh the concern now it
will be
how will this uh president elect
ibrahimovic be able to convince the
public
that he can uh turn things around for
them of course the economy being the
number one issue for iranians
uh it's important to point out that
ibrahim raisi is
the numbers that he has gotten in this
election is
now going to be considered known to be
the lowest
turnout voter turnout in iran's history
since the revolution of 1979.
voter turnout is at 48 percent the
interior ministry
said that the number of votes cast they
have the final number for that it's 28.6
million iranians
went to the polls on friday uh ibrahim
raisi of course got a
landslide victory we also know that the
current president hassan rouhani has now
visited ibrahim baisi it at his office
within the judiciary in tehran
to congratulate him in person he knows
what task awaits him of course
and the country's 13th government will
be formed in the beginning of august
the president hassan rouhani will no
longer will no doubt be
giving him a few um updates about what
to expect when he takes office at that
time
tell us more about ibrahim raisi then
and about his politics
well he is a man that we know to be very
close to the supreme leader and to the
conservative establishment here ibrahim
wears a black turban which is a sign
that he is a sayyid
meaning that his family claims lineage
to the prophet muhammad
he was born in mashad which is also the
birthplace of the supreme leader
ayatollah ali khamenei
it is iran's second largest city in
northeast of the country
he was appointed as the head of the
astonish foundation in mashad
in 2016 a position appointed by the
supreme leader himself
because it is the foundation that is in
charge of imam reza shrine
and that foundation is also involved
with
the country's economy and the politics
as well so it's a very important
position
he had that job until 2019 when he was
again
appointed as the head of the judiciary
by the supreme leader
so we know him to be a man of very very
high status within the system he uh
hasn't said much about his policies he
has said that he
plans to tackle corruption within
government that was also his platform
when he was assigned the portfolio of
the judiciary he wanted to fight
corruption within that department and
that is also what he intends to do when
he takes office
al jazeera's daughter jabari reporting
live from tehran